this is a fantastic and stunning story
and it relates to the now I guess I'll
say six or more allegations of sexual
assault against the Alabama Republican
Senate candidate Roy Moore when there
are sexual assault allegations generally
you always have this faction that likes
to say the allegations are made up we
can't believe the allegations but there
are also some who are more specific and
they say it's not that the women aren't
credible as a general thing it's that
anyone who wants to hurt a politician
can go to the media and say so-and-so
assaulted me just to get stories written
about them to hurt them politically and
the argument is from some particularly
on the right that the media whoever the
media is are just so eager to publish
this type of story that they will do it
on the say-so of one alleged victim
without actually trying to fact-check or
do background research and the truth is
that when the Washington Post published
the stories of women who said we were
sexually assaulted by Roy Moore many
right-wingers did exactly this they were
we're very quickly writing it off as oh
it's the Washington Post doing a
political hit piece to hurt Roy Moore in
the election the right-wingers pointing
out Oh Amazon or Jeff Bezos owns the
Washington Post and he's a big left
winger I don't even know if that's true
actually but in any case saying you
can't trust the reports because the
Washington Post is not really
researching this stuff they're
publishing nonsense they've not done
their due diligence to figure out are
these women maybe telling the truth or
are these women just making stuff up and
this is where it gets great okay
remember this guy James O'Keefe he's the
sort of right-wing troll provocateur who
likes to do undercover recordings to try
to sting different people and so often
his sting attempts completely backfire
he did this at acorn he did this with
Planned Parenthood there's a very long
list of them and many of them have
absolutely horribly backfired on him
he's connected to this organization
Project Veritas and what Project Veritas
and James O'Keefe did was send a woman
to the Washington Post
to lie to straight-up lie and say ROI
more sexually assaulted me and the idea
was if the Washington Post publishes
this then Project Veritas can come out
and say look this woman went to the
Washington Post made up this story about
Roy Moore and they published it and it
would sort of serve to discredit all of
the previous accusers of Roy Moore so
what did the woman do she got in touch
with the Washington Post she had a
meeting with them and in that meeting
she said I was 15 years old I had a
sexual relationship with Roy Moore where
I got pregnant and ultimately I got an
abortion and again the idea was get
Washington Post to publish this to then
say we tricked them and we can't believe
any of the women what are the Washington
Post a well they investigated the claims
and they started to see them as sort of
suspect they thought maybe this is a
fake story first the Washington Post
noticed that there were some
inconsistencies in the woman's story and
then they went online and they found an
internet posting from a woman who said
basically I'm moving to New York I've
accepted a job working in the
conservative media movement to combat
the lies and deceit of the liberal
mainstream media I'll be using my skills
as a researcher and fact checker to help
our movement and the Washington Post
research team had reason to believe that
that post was from the woman that met
with them and it's kind of weird if you
say well I'm moving to New York to work
in conservative activism and right after
you moved to New York what you do is
call it The Washington Post and say hey
Roy more sexually assaulted me when I
was 15 so the Washington Post goes and
confronts the woman and she insists
listen I'm not working with anyone I'm
just a woman telling my story of sexual
assault well Washington Post was getting
more and more suspicious so they started
a sort of paying attention to where it
was that the woman was going what is it
that she's doing during the day and they
caught her walking into the office of
none other than James o keeffe's Project
Veritas so then the Washington Post says
let's confront James O'Keefe about this
woman and here is what happened when the
Washington Post tried to get James
O'Keefe to tell them hey is this woman
working for you because she came to us
and said Roy Moore sexually assaulted
her
thank you very much so have a great day
my question for you guys well here's the
deal so the other night Wednesday night
in Virginia there's a woman who
approached that inspired by Project
Veritas no we just wanted to confirm
that the woman we believe is Jamie
Phillips works for Project Veritas she
code up she showed up here at this
morning it's really cute
you guys are borrowing our techniques
right now
well here's the here's the problem
someone someone approached The
Washington Post reporter yeah saying
that she was impregnated by Roy Rob was
that truthful or was that a problem the
problem is you're busy so if you'd like
to make an appointment please call our
office for make an appointment ok thank
you if you're not involved you pretty
easily just say no we don't we don't
know who that is
we don't know what you're talking about
you don't do this and then there was a
follow up and James O'Keefe was asked
are you working with Roy Moore in some
capacity and he also didn't answer that
so as a result what is the Washington
Post done well they've published the
woman's off-the-record comments which
include her original contact with The
Washington Post saying she has something
but she needs to keep herself safe and
the entire story just basically
completely fell apart
this was a clear sting operation to make
the Washington Post seem as though they
will report any allegation of sexual
assault and the Washington Post didn't
they investigated and they did the right
thing
they were the targets of a sting
operation to discredit Roy Moore's
accusers this vindicates the Washington
Post and I can imagine the people at
Project Veritas sitting around scheming
thinking oh this is just gonna be so
brilliant and then it completely blows
up in their face and the real problem
this is what concerns me is that some
people will misunderstand the story and
they'll misunderstand the headline and
they will think that the stories about
Roy Moore that have previously been
published were all false because when
you look at some of the headlines for
the story a woman approached the
Washington Post with dramatic false
tales about Roy Moore if you just read
that and I'm curious Pat whether you
agree with me about this might you not
come away thinking that all of the
stories we've heard so far are the fake
ones when the truth is this makes those
other stories more believable yeah I
mean I think it's one thing to go out
there and try to discredit the
mainstream media sure some people don't
like them to begin with easy target when
you're trying to discredit previous
sexual misconduct Ledger's that's
horrible
you are going and specifically trying to
say the however what I have all five or
six gone through the Washington Post I
don't even know at this point the idea
is to cast doubt upon how truthful the
original accusers are because it was the
Washington Post that made some of those
reports and the truth is we now can
trust the Washington Post more than
maybe we did and we should be skeptical
of every media outlet of course but the
fact that the Washington Post didn't
just rush and say hey here's another one
let's publish this one too they actually
investigated and they said you know what
this was an attempt to sting us and they
they don't do it the way that the right
wing says they do it number one that's
why this didn't work and number two this
is why it's particularly ridiculous for
Trump to write off the New York Times in
the Washington Post as fake news
left-wing bomb throwers Washington
posted the exact right thing here and I
applaud them for it 100% the video you
just finished watching was made possible
by you through the membership program
you can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership